is it okay to say that we could probably
never rely on them to help us again
because honestly it just feels like we
have just
left them
high and dry
i think that's what a lot of service
members are feeling right now is uh
you know we're ingrained it's ingrained
into our brains from the from the very
beginning of training that we don't
leave anybody behind we don't leave
people that are alive behind and we
don't leave our dead on the field either
and um
and i understand that this situation is
uh is being dealt with at a
international level and i understand
that but
there has to be something done there we
can't leave
uh we can't leave these people behind
and if we look forward into our strategy
what are they gonna what are the next
interpreters for the next we're gonna
say yeah uh you know if we don't help
these people and uh and at least secure
the promises for the sivs and the
americans that have been promised what
does that say to the rest of the world
yeah but the administration has not been
much of a help they can't get out of
their own way they clearly are
disorganized scott how many people do
you think americans do you think are in
country in afghanistan
i i think the number of the 1500 number
you're hearing is very low and i i got
to say man i i am absolutely ashamed uh
of the leadership of my country right
now not the men and women in uniform who
are on the ground and others who are
civilians that are helping that are
working hard to save lives but i'm
absolutely baffled that that no one's
been fired astounded that there's been
zero resignations in protest this was
biden didn't have a binary choice it
wasn't should we stay or should we go he
had a range of options and strategies
and what has occurred is an epic failure
that could lead to the largest
american hostage situation in our
nation's history brings me to the most
important question
if we leave on the 31st which means we
got to start packing up right away right
now
do we have any leverage to get our
people out afterwards let alone our
afghan
interpreters
the reality is the taliban is on their
best behavior right now and that's not
very good and the only reason for that
is because of the thousands of american
troops that are there right now uh when
we leave i think all hell is going to
break loose and i think this nation
needs leaders elected needs the leaders
appointed who are willing to walk
through the fires of hell to get
american citizens out safe and i got to
tell you i want to i want to ask you
brian and ask your audience we have an
operation going right now that could
save the lives of hundreds of women and
children right now and i'm asking for
your prayers for success
[Music]
okay
all right ladies and gentlemen
welcome to the wayne dupree show yeah
yeah all right
we're live uh
as you know
oh well let me introduce liabella and
brian smith
um to catch up on things that are
happening right now uh i know charles a
lot of people are pissed off right now
especially at what's happening on the
ground over there in afghanistan
multiple people are injured some are
dead
uh two explosions
uh
the
the the gates
as of right now the gates have been
closed we're getting reports also that
two of the gates are being um uh
sealed shut
so that um there's
that's a that's a big danger too because
when you only have one entry point
that's that's where the one entry point
is yeah the one entry point is just
strictly for security purposes
you ain't you're you're leaving through
the sky you're not coming in and out
that that gate is not for going in and
out okay
right
okay right that's you're not
one entry point that's it
if you need to leave you're taken to the
sky
okay but yeah but
i mean that
that one engine point still
kind of scares me a little bit right
right because you can't right yeah it's
a jerk
yeah it is a turkey shoot um
so um
brian and leah uh
you've been
watching some of the developments uh
going on
there's there's no way that you can't be
angry at joe biden for making this for
making a decision to remove the troops
and not thinking of the civilians over
there uh we were talking about it
earlier
um the hostage
the there's a potential hostage huge
hazardous um
situation that could happen
i don't know i mean
i i don't i don't know what to say for
the people that are older right now i
mean
um
it'd be crazy to say okay find a place
and hide
you know but you never know who's gonna
turn people in
that but but certainly
if if you're over in
afghanistan um
i'm sorry
i'm sorry yeah i mean it's it's like
it's like um i didn't vote for this
empty shell of a thing that guy got no
he's empty
he's not even there
he can't even we were talking about this
earlier off there he can't even get to a
press conference kamala did it
yeah
we are
it's 15 days before the anniversary of 9
11.
15 days before the anniversary of 9 11.
we've had an isis suicide bomber walk
into the gate and blow himself up and
kill americans and kill troops
15 days before the 20th anniversary of 9
11.
do we all remember 9 11 do we all
remember how terrified how disgusting it
was to watch terrorists attack our own
and now here we are 15 days before 9 11
and the same thing is going down again
we have a hostage situation now isis k
is there the taliban is there
and american citizens are still stuck as
joe biden turns and walks away from the
podium
15 days before the anniversary of 9 11.
and now we're hearing reports that
germany's out
peace deuces
we're gone we don't want nothing to do
with this hot mess
if i was another country i wouldn't
either think about this the ragtag band
of nomads who run the deserts and
slaughter to live i mean that's
literally how they live they slaughter
and conquer like genghis khan i mean the
days of old they live like that now to
this day
they are able to garner
uh
billions of dollars worth of american
military equipment
attempting to get more money from banks
and and rape and pillage and do whatever
they want free to go
and the g7
the most advanced countries in the world
and no this someone said it's not the
same as 911 no no it's not the same as 9
11. in fact it's not the same of
anything that's ever happened you can't
compare this to anything
that's how sick this is i am just as
upset as today as i was on 9 11. there's
going to be more than 2 000 americans
that die from this
think about it y'all
you have americans
right now the u.s embassy is saying
don't go to the airport
so
so you have americans that are hiding
because there's night time over there
too
that are hiding they don't know
where to where to come out where to go
when they do come out
um who to trust they they really don't
know who to trust
because you don't know who's going to
turn you in
you don't know who's going to
to uh uh or
you don't know who is going to set up
another bomb
by a whole lot of
by a known group well a known area where
americans might be
somebody might set off another bomb
over there you don't know and
and the weekend's coming ladies the
weekend is coming
you don't think that these people just
gonna take off on the weekend i was
telling brian only earlier
when these people hit
they're not hitting to say hey look look
look look what i did look no they're
gonna
i hit that one i'm gonna hit that one
over there i'm gonna hit that one over
there
i want to show because they want to show
strength they want to make sure for
and that creates
a recruiting tool to bring more people
in
breaking news the taliban tried to get
their hands on afghan central banks
nearly 10 billion
in reserve
but most of that money is in new york
i've got a question for you too
we um to both of y'all we were talking
about it earlier in the week but
uh you know all those men that were
taken off and stuff and everything like
that all those men
somebody was able to get to
the airport with a suicide bomb
and blow up this morning was able to get
there
to the airport and blow up
all those men at the beginning of the
week
got on
the plane
and now they're in some air b and b
place
you can't tell me that there was no
terrorists in those groups that were
being flown out
at the beginning i saw a report where a
lot of them are being fed and taken care
of in ramstein germany the largest one
of the largest air force bases that we
have in europe
um but yeah on the ground just to kind
of backtrack a little bit when i was
stationed in italy back in the 90s i
mean i'm not italian but and i didn't
have this beard
it was clean shaving but i i stood out
like a sore thumb
all americans stand out like a sort of
you really can look oh wow
he's not supposed to be here imagine
that now in afghanistan
where the skin color is now completely
different
the the the body shape is completely
different uh we're a little bit heavier
and we're also
many inches taller than most of those
folks in that in that nation
you will stick out like a sore thumb
shelter in place i mean i hate to say
that but
at this point
help's not coming gates are locked go
home don't come here
um
lots of problems
and back to wayne's point yeah the
airbnbs are pretty much aiding and
embedding terrorists right now of course
terrorists snuck through they hate our
country um they're happy they got a free
ride in it takes a lot of effort to try
to get into america uh now maybe not
nowadays since um the muslim ban is gone
but anyways uh yeah they're here and the
thing is isis k has only just begun
i had mentioned on an earlier show that
there's californians stuck in
afghanistan right now msnbc saying turn
around and go back home but there's
californians that went over there for
vacation loads of them they don't have a
home and they're stuck there and they're
still in there today and this was my
question for you guys is does joe biden
come out on 9 11
after the troops are gone and this
settles down and says that this was a
victory for us and he says here i stand
on 9 11 any american that wanted to come
out of afghanistan we got out this is
what we considered a victory is he going
to use 911
is he going to use an abused 911 to say
that this was a victory because you know
how they gaslight you know what they do
right right i was looking back uh
talking about the uh the fall of saigon
and then wayne brought up the hostage
situation in iran and i was looking that
over uh yeah there were 52 hostages for
almost a year during jimmy carter's
re-election year
and it was a hot hot mess for jimmy
carter couldn't do anything i mean he's
a peanut farmer he's weak he's an
appeaser he was not a leader and ronald
reagan made that happen
you know when leah was saying you can't
compare this to anything
you really can't because
iran was only 50 when i say only 52
hostages happened to diplomats and
american civilians
they were saved they were brought out uh
uh
i don't want to speak before it soon but
i mean we now know people have died
yeah i mean
you would think that the government
would give a whole lot of protection
uh
or that they would look to protect but
this is not i mean afghanistan is not
the united states of america
and
you wouldn't i mean anybody in their
right mind wouldn't have removed troops
without thinking about the americans
first
except for joe biden but
let me show you let me give you an idea
of how these people think the taliban
have made public
and private commitments to provide and
permit safe passage for americans
for third country nationals and afghans
at risk going forward past august 31st
the united states our allies and
partners and more than half of the
world's countries
114 and all
issued a statement making it clear to
the taliban that they have a
responsibility
to hold to that commitment and provide
safe passage
for anyone who wishes to leave the
country not just for the duration of our
evacuation and relocation mission but
for every day thereafter
oh really
did y'all hear that
who's he talking about
what what is he doing does he know what
he's doing he needs to step down so so
he so
basically he's saying the taliban
made assurances for safety right okay so
why aren't people safe today i don't
that's what i'm saying like who's he
talking he's talking about taliban in
afghanistan because apparently he's
living on a different planet
yeah how do you negotiate this is
negotiating with terrorists oh now it's
a and it's a hostage situation now it's
gonna become a money situation right
going all the way back to the founding
fathers who originally ran in and
appeased to the barbary pirates who were
islamic by the way in case anybody
didn't know we've been running into
islamic uh extremists or
uh conservatives that hold the quran
dear near to their hearts since the
beginning of america's con inception and
the founding fathers made that statement
we will no longer negotiate with
terrorists that's when it began
now we're negotiating with terrorists
and why all of a sudden is joe trusting
terrorists how can you trust a terrorist
how can you trust the taliban they
didn't just change overnight
um many people many people are now
coming out i mean look we've been we've
been slamming um joe all week long
which has been a good well actually for
the last two weeks we've been slamming
joe for last two weeks about the stupid
decisions that he's making
if if there was an election next year
joe is not getting elected i don't and
and even
even in three more years after all the
things that have happened within the
first nine months joe is not getting it
like
no president that i have that i have
seen
in the white house
gets elected
you basically say he's linked up but how
do you clean it up
right i mean
i can think of one people
no no no i mean for joe for joe how did
how did they fix
now he but i can think of one way
but i bet you can i i
i heard the first time and i was like
i'm gonna let it go but then we said the
second time i was like okay all right i
know what she's talking about she's
talking about her final solution
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah she's talking
about she's talking about scorched earth
scoring woman scorched earth type of
thing all right all right i don't need
to go i'm just gonna say it he needs to
go
it's time no okay okay but here's the
thing though
we gotta come
i can't even say i know i know he has to
go too
she has to go too okay okay so she says
who's third y'all closely just gets in
just for a couple minutes only for a
couple minutes and then they vote on who
the vice president president is and
republicans get a choice and democrats
get a choice so that's okay we need both
of them to go pelosi comes in for like
10 minutes and then republicans get a
vote on somebody and the democrats get a
vote on somebody that's where we that's
what needs to be done this is that bad
well but they'll pass a couple of four
five six seven trillion dollars worth of
budgets before then and then and they
already did that right they're right now
they're sleeping in it well we're
focused on afghanistan
and now they're going on fire and
money's being dropped yeah oh yeah
everything's burning
3.5 trillion the house has already
signed it or uh well did they pass it
did they pass it i think they did yeah i
think they did pass it yeah
okay so that means that um
and then they jet it and now and and now
the explosion
um well i'm just gonna say it's gonna
get worse right it's gonna get much
worse and what we have to remember is
you know the haqqani network used to run
the kabul attack network is now in
charge of security in kabul you compound
that with the 5 000 that we made the
afghans released from prison and then
you compound that further with all the
prisons being empty now of isis
coruscant and al-qaeda
and and the taliban and so what we now
have is a new epicenter of jihadist
terrorism that is going to be a grave
threat to the world so the question is
what are we going to do now are we going
to start being serious people again are
we going to stop talking about we need
to engage the taliban about the future
of afghanistan and maybe instead engage
afghans other than the taliban about the
future of afghanistan and then really
double down on our counterterrorism
efforts broadly with partners you know
across the world because the situation
is going to get much worse even than
what we're seeing
everything you lay out is appropriate
and everything you talk about is the
decision that now goes to the
commander-in-chief how does he respond
well we have the capability the question
is do we have the will right we defeated
ourselves in this war the taliban did
not defeat us we defeated ourselves and
so the question is can we muster the
will will the american people demand
more of their leaders that they actually
in in war try to achieve a noble outcome
rather than surrender uh to a terrorist
organization
h.r mcmaster thank you we'll call on you
again in the coming days
you know
the american people
rarely
does an event happen that brings
american people together
wow it happens it's sad it's sad but
it's true yeah right
rarely does it happen
i mean because honestly we should all
really be on the same page anyway and
trying to move the country forward
usually it takes a major issue
that doesn't have anything to do with
the pocketbook to bring us all together
patriotic
yep well
i don't know if this is it yet
it should be but i don't know if this is
it yet
and i i mean and and i'm being very
honest with you
because
some people are still defending joe
okay
uh because their idea is there was no
way for this not to happen
that's what they're thinking
there's no way
i mean this was going to happen anywhere
and
i'll throw it to both of y'all do you
think
that there was no i mean
was this inevitable
for this to happen
the way is happening right now
no and look at joe biden's record
internationally look at his record when
it comes to all of this he has a
terrible record uh when it comes to
making decisions like this and number
two until i'm blue in the face i will
repeat it i get it that we had to remove
troops out of afghanistan but it didn't
have to be done this way there's no
reason to pull troops out before you get
americans out it was completely effed up
and that's just the end of it no one can
defend that no one can say otherwise and
you know what this has obama's stench
all over it he's the one who created
isis was created by obama
obama created vice president joe biden
and now we've got joe biden in office
you got obama stink all over this and
that's how i feel she'd turn it into a
glass desert and a resort of sorts or
some kind of museum
uh
oh and you let the guy get go from gitmo
we don't we don't have a general patent
anymore we really don't
that's why this is what it is
we need those uh that greatest
generation that was
that had whether they had the stomach or
not they knew they had to win at all
cost we have to win at all costs uh
the korean conflict kind of weakened us
the vietnam conflict really super
weakened us and we walked away from both
of those and now it's all political and
now there's no stomach for it uh but
there's big money for it goes to john
mccain can testify to that that there's
big money for all these perpetual little
wars of wars and to have isis around to
have the taliban around to have al qaeda
around terrorizing causing problems iran
state spon sponsor of terror around
we can continue the perpetuation of
billions and trillions of dollars that
make its way back to these politicians
these big ceos big companies i'm i've
got a friend that works for the dod and
there's a company that does nothing but
make fuses
for all the bombs and the entire
military right here out of cincinnati
the the company is is beyond wealthy the
money is flowing like rivers
that's all they do just make fuses so
what about all those people i mean it's
just big money
and wayne i forgot to say
obama also released the guy from i love
how you're like um here she goes again
what now leah what do you need to say
now the fab five when he looks sorry
wayne um
the guy that uh obama released from
guantanamo bay is now in charge of the
taliban yeah there was a total of five
of them
obama all over it yeah
but we got bo bird but we got bo bird
dog back
yeah and we got another one got that
traitor back um
you said something we don't have patent
anymore
right
we have but we do have general miley
we lose miley cyrus you saw what they
did to general flynn and i'm not saying
i agree with everything general flynn
has said or done in the past but i know
him
as a general and and
that's about the closest thing we've
ever gotten and you saw what they did to
him they railed him out of there
yeah but like you said patton
patton
patton took on congress though man i
mean if it wasn't for him yeah these
campaigns wouldn't know what he was
taking on congress you know i mean he
got trouble he got in trouble with
civilians in congress you know
you know eerily right after the war he
was in a car wreck that everybody
survived
except him
everybody in the car even the driver
well i know everybody survived but he
did not i didn't know that check this
out trey yingsten coverage from there
trey what have you heard
bill good morning we're following this
breaking news out of kabul right now
reports of an explosion outside of the
abbey gate one of the main three gates
on the ground there
at the airport in kabul remember there
were thousands of people lining up over
the past several days trying to get out
of the country not just afghan civilians
but also for nationals including
american and british citizens isis k
though a small organization in eastern
afghanistan the k stands for corazon
corazon province in eastern afghanistan
this is an offshoot of the islamic state
that started back in 2014 and they were
responsible for a lot of attacks in
afghanistan especially from 2015 to
2017. some reports indicate upwards of
250 attacks both shooting and explosive
attacks against afghan and pakistani
civilians during that time period now
the afghan security forces when they
were in control of the country
oftentimes would launch operations
against this group we saw images in in
recent months in cities like jalalabad
afghanistan where they were able to come
in and and take out many of these
extremist fighters but again over the
past several days we heard concern from
not only american but also british
intelligence officials about this group
isis k a very small but strong
organization when it comes to these
extremist attacks and there were a
specific threats this led the us state
department and what's left of the
embassy in kabul operating out of the
airport there to urge americans simply
to shelter in place they had been
issuing these orders every so often over
the past week following the taliban
takeover of afghanistan because there
were concerns that americans and any
civilians could be targeted on their way
to the airport or outside these gates
remember when we look at these types of
attacks you see i have a large group of
civilians in one area you also have
foreign soldiers including americans
outside of these gates trying to keep
some sense of order and this was the
exact piece of of a possibility that u.s
officials were concerned about part of
the reason we heard the pentagon and the
department of defense try to ramp up
these evacuations in recent days in the
past 24 hours more than 13 000 people
evacuated that according to the dod and
also that brings the total to about 95
000 certainly some progress but we do
know there were those thousands of
people outside of the gates of the
airport and when you hear these reports
of an explosion and then small arms fire
you have to think about where this was
located we were on the ground on sunday
in kabul and as we were there you could
hear gunfire in the distance there were
was smoke rising up from the horizon the
area around the airport was secure to an
extent where the perimeter was
established by the americans but beyond
that it was pretty much no man's land
and that was the area where u.s
intelligence officials were specifically
concerned that not taliban fighters but
isis k militants could simply walk up to
a crowd of people like we saw these
images and then detonate some sort of
device we don't know a lot of details
specifically about this story as it's
developing as we speak but reports on
the ground do indicate an explosion a
large explosion outside of the abbey
gate at the kabul airport happening just
this hour and reports of multiple people
injured as a result bill thank you trey
we also have breaking news that at least
40 dead and 120 wounded with the
majority in critical condition arriving
to the cool airports
40.
there's 40 dead 120 wounded and the
majority of those wounded are in
critical condition not not knowing if
they will survive or not at the
hospitals uh following the terror attack
okay
um
ladies and gentlemen we are dwayne
deprecia we are
uh let me let me uh um
let me talk about our sponsor real quick
uh
sponsor is my pillow mypillars.com
forward slash radio specials make sure
that you check out uh our awesome
sponsor they uh
they make it possible
that we can provide to you
um some of the best sleep and comfort
that you have had or will have in your
whole entire lifetime you can go there
mypillar.com you can get up to 66
percent off on your product purchase
use codename wayne we
have many other products we love the
products uh
my top three
are the mattress chopper uh the weighted
blanket
and right now
i think i have to push my on the
moccasin men slippers up there at the
top three
but um
leo what's your top three i like the
sheets and the towels and i just got the
robe
wow that sucker is heavy and it is cozy
i could wear it all day my dog ran away
yesterday the neighbor had to bring her
back and i was in my robe i didn't care
if i looked like the woman from the
christmas story i didn't care i don't
care what time of day it was i was like
yeah i'm here in my my pillow robe and
i'm not taking it off
i love it
brown where's your top three
sorry about that my top three
uh definitely the mattress topper the
foam mattress
and the adjustable uh base
for the bed adjusts all these different
positions it's got a zero g
a pre-programmed that puts you in a
position that feels like
there's no weight on any of your joints
and there's like a halo glow
light
in the at night time it's really faint
you can't see it when you're laying in
the bed but when you come back or you're
leaving you kind of look down you kick
just enough
that's pretty nice
we ladies and gentlemen we have
they uh
they allow us
to promote their products
and again we have some we have some and
this is the mattress operator that we're
talking about they have two two inches
three inches worth they also come with
pillows so if you were looking to get my
pillows
you can also get a mattress topper to go
with it
and
uh
we were talking about the giza sheets
you can get the giza sheets to go on top
of that
okay but you have to use the code name
wayne
and again you get up to 66 off on your
product purchase uh they even have these
go anywhere my pillows
you take them anywhere use them on your
couch your car
uh
use it anywhere outside whatever they're
versatile and they come in many multiple
colors and patterns
so call 1-800-544-8939
you can also call customer service
1-800-308-1299
or you can just go to the website
mypillar.com forward slash radio
specials
and use the code name wayne now
if you decide that uh you want some
other specials other than what is
underneath the radio specials button
you can use the code name wayne on all
products again you can use the code name
wayne on all products
on the my pillow website and still get
up to 66
off
on
your
um
on your purchase so i just want to make
sure that y'all know about that so
thanks for everybody for tuning in
well first of all there's no elegant way
to lose a wall we lost this floor 15
years ago all joe biden was doing is
telling us what time it is and the
hysterical and stupid coverage of the
mainstream press this is it's just it's
been awful just read new york
wow that blew up in his face
wow
um
that that's the same guy that was saying
that uh the democrats would have
remained in charge for 40 years when
barack obama was elected president that
was james carvel last night uh there's a
lot of egg on a lot of democrats faces
right now
uh yes they still have the white house
yes they still control the house
and and whatnot
but uh you're talking you're probably
gonna talk about a major overhaul
come in 2022
um in the house
and and and
don't get it twisted it's not it's it's
not the it's not anything that the
republicans have done good
they won't have a man i mean you know
they'll come out and say well we got a
mandate because america doesn't like
what the democrats are doing
ain't that
it's not that
ain't nobody else to vote for yeah
there's nobody else to vote for you
right you only got one or two and we had
an independent come on and try and say
oh we independents we got control they
need us i'm like no no you ain't got no
control man sorry
if we continue down this road the ccp
and the taliban's gonna have the house
in the white house we're not going to
have the rights to vote anymore
i contend they have an ear in the white
house for sure i mean joe biden and his
son look china china teams up with with
the taliban i mean you look you've got
the unholy trinity down there in
afghanistan right now you got the
taliban you've got isis k you've got al
qaeda now afghanistan's looking like a
damn pep rally for all the terrorists
and this is what we've got to put up
with and then you've got china going oh
all right there's trillion dollars worth
of assets underneath their feet
what
what happens if that takes over i mean
america could become
last well they're talking about the
economy that's just going to absolutely
implode it's going to fall apart so yeah
what civil war
um
i would say more of an invasion and that
we just can't handle it because our
leaders are so incompetent and they take
us down and we never saw it coming
that's what i feel right i feel like an
old school invasion it could turn out
like uh like libya muammar gaddafi
i mean now it's just ragtag bands
different factions of warlords going at
each other
um
you know and all the innocents all the
innocents the children and the women
oh they get wrapped up into uh slavery
just what happens in those cultures
i fear for like um more like these
cartels that come in i think you'll see
more suicide bomb attacks in america
you'll see america almost become
decimated in that way to where you will
see the taliban start to take over areas
that they've attacked and deemed theirs
and i think that if we don't get control
of this that's the kind of america
you'll see like michigan won't be
michigan anymore literally the taliban
will run
michigan
dearborn michigan is little iraq that's
exactly why i use them as an example
first because they'll be the first state
to go
deep
dear bonnie stan and then you got muslim
soda right um
yeah exactly so that's what i'm saying
it'll start to just trickle down and we
will become no more united states
little by little they'll start to to
attack us and take over small cities
what do you call um out there in oregon
portland
what do you call it
no because you got you got um
the muslims taking over michigan i
yeah michigan and minnesota
then you got antifa and them taking over
the the far west
northwest
okay
you got the the gang uh the the border
open situation
down in new mexico texas type of thing
arizona
along that way
and
who can say that it's not
all planned
to destroy america from within from i
mean
the these legislators seem like they're
agents for other countries or
agents for other people stalin said it
stalin said america will fall without a
bullet being shot yeah and god forbid
damned if he was right and god forbid if
these vaccines do have
long-term side effects and we're giving
them to our troops
and then all of a sudden our troops are
all ill and we don't have a we don't
have an army we don't have a we don't
have a navy we don't have troops because
they're all
sick well either that is sick or
coloring their hair purple you know what
i'm saying though
that's legit could you take down
someone's army with with a shot
with a vaccine you know when you look
back at army's past when militaries
passed when when they started dabbling
in the
alternative lifestyles that's usually
when the countries fell
i was shocked to hear
that now in the air force overseas that
you man man woman woman you get married
pay you've got married status and i'm
just like what
yeah
yeah you get married housing married
paid married status two dudes
that that's not a melody and and oh i
was gonna bring this up earlier
why do they hate us so much
why does the islamic caliphate hate us
so much
they hate us because of homosexuality
they hate us because of uh abortions
they hate us for for all the reasons
that us christians don't like the left
this is why the islamic church and i'm
not saying they're right they're crazy
they're out there and they're willing to
kill but but
we're doing things that are that are
beyond
moral guard rails
um and it it it's just the fall of the
civilization
that's why i said general milly well
miley is more woke than miley cyrus you
know it's illegal to have an abortion in
saudi arabia
i mean
it's been legal here since 1973. it's
been you know you could have an abortion
in in israel
it's been legal since i think like 1976
1980 something like that
the christian nations
who claim to be founded on moral
guidelines and moral guard rails
well i um
okay let me let me move to
uh our our top story for i mean because
this this uh this bombing was one thing
but uh
you know how we were complaining that
biden was
ripping up
trump's executive orders and how trump
wasn't able to stop
uh
obama's executive order went to daca
well yesterday
uh by nat biden administration got
slapped in the face
with the uh remain in mexico policy
um skoda said uh don't you can't touch
that
and honestly that was a huge win
not
he has win for trump but it's a huge win
for america because
the the rule of law basically because
basically what what what democrats were
allowing was that was it um
catch and release after release right
and
uh
but
it it was more like
release and never come back you know so
when trump saw that he was like let me
work out a deal of mexico
and yeah we all
will meet
immigrant a and immigrant b
but we're going to send them back over
so that we can look at their asylum and
see if they're legit dealing a major
blow to the biden administration and
reinstating the remain in mexico policy
this after texas sued over the program
suspension claiming it placed a burden
on local governments forced to provide
services to immigrants texas attorney
general ken paxton was behind the
lawsuit and he joins us now live okay
ken so first off this program keeps
migrants in mexico as they await these
hearings especially right now with the
influx and the surge at the border and
not only that but the the surgeon
coveted cases how important is it for
them to remain in mexico while they
await these hearings
so incredibly important this is one of
president trump's i think greatest
successes because we he had the same
problem he instituted this program
because all of these immigrants were
being told by immigration lawyers hey
come to come to the united states you'll
cross the border tell a border agent
that you're claiming asylum
and then you get to disappear into the
country for
years you don't ever have to come back
and so this idea that you have to stay
in mexico and wait for your asylum
hearing is a really good idea especially
when only about 14 percent of these
people qualify so it was greatly
successful under the trump
administration we're hoping that
reinstituting it will really help along
the border and then i want to get to
this this is uh dhs's response to the
supreme court's ruling it says dhs has
appealed the district court's order and
will continue to vigorously challenge it
as the appeal process continues however
dhs will comply with the order in good
faith how long could this appeal process
take you know it could take a long time
but because we would still have to go
through like a like a little trial uh on
the merits of the case however we won a
preliminary injunction at the district
court of the federal court in texas we
then took it to the fifth circuit we won
again we took at the u.s they took it to
the us we won again
so when you do that the court is saying
you're like likely to win on the merits
and when they're granting an injunction
so i feel very confident that they can
appeal it and we can go through the
trial process but pretty sure we're
going to win and we already have the
injunction in place so we're fairly
confident we're going forward in the
right direction obviously it's important
for you know the safety of america for
people to to come into this this country
legally but
texas in particular right now how
important is it for just the state of
texas
oh it's it's incredible i just met with
a bunch of ranchers a couple days ago
and they are so frustrated they're so
fearful because they're they're not only
is their property being destroyed but
they fear for their lives i've met with
the leaders along the borders they're
fearful they don't know how to deal with
the influx they're worried about covet
killing their people they're worried
about the importation of fentanyl which
is dramatically up because of the border
crisis and human trafficking sex
trafficking all kinds of different
crimes so we have a lot of problems
related to this and a lot of obviously
massively increased law enforcement
costs along with health care costs so
yeah it has a dramatic in fact impact on
our state and as they import these
people all over the country with covid
you know this is going to affect the
health and safety of of citizens across
the country as these people are moved
around secretly by the administration
and and with this administration with
with biden's words um
do you think that the president respects
the rule of law especially when it comes
to states rights or is he basically just
saying i can do whatever i want it
doesn't matter uh you know about statute
or any of the rights of the states
no there's no doubt he looks at the
federal laws
is sort of his choice if he wants to
follow what has been passed by congress
his job is actually not to change the
laws it's to follow them whether he
likes them or not i have to do the same
thing in the executive branch he doesn't
do that he says look i don't have to
follow the laws i was elected president
this constitutional thing doesn't work
for me so he literally tells people not
to enforce the law and that's what's
happening along the border that's we
have such a disaster and you can compare
what donald trump did a year ago to
where we are now the numbers are
dramatically different the results are
horrible and it's because we have a
president who literally is out of
control
you know um we have we have breaking
news
um
based on what what we had this morning
let me go ahead and put the tweet up
right now just then you uk issues alert
to airline is not to take their planes
below 25 000 feet while in afghanistan
airspace
which probably means that they're firing
on um
firing on the planes yeah the rpgs that
they have that are ours
yeah have a range about 900 meters which
is about a half a mile and then they
explode
uh 25 000 feet is four and a half miles
almost five miles so as long as they
stay
yeah as long as they stay up four and a
half five miles up in the air they'll be
fine
and if they get locked in on that's when
they're supposed to shoot their flares
so that way the lock-in gets confused
and then follows the flares
well these are
these are airliners these are right yeah
but i'm saying brother yeah yeah
yeah for the military
um
okay
so
on to the border what you just talked
about there yep
he messed that up too it didn't have to
be like that all you had to do was keep
what trump was doing just like
afghanistan just keep what trump was
doing follow the plan
i'm not i'm not understanding
at this point i have to ask you guys
both a question
is it that joe's incompetent and his
entire staff have not a clue how to run
the country or at some point i have to
question it is this done on purpose are
you punishing the country because it's
you can't be this stupid you really
can't my eight-year-old was like why did
they take troops out before they got out
the people mommy like why why not get
out the people first like an
eight-year-old understands that concept
an eight-year-old understands that you
should close a border because you don't
know who's coming through so at what
point do we stop saying oh joe's just a
dumb butt and he has dementia and then
we say it like it is is he trying to
harm the country is he trying to bring
us down just because orange man bad and
we don't want to do anything that trump
did
well i will say barack obama was set out
to punish americans
and american way of life
i agree with you this looks to be a
continuation of that
to punish people that didn't accept the
fundamental transformation correct yeah
and he he loves islam he loves isis he
called him isil just because he was
trying to respect the real name yeah
islamic state and the levant not islamic
state in syria
islamic state um iran and syria
now what does the k stand for again i
know that guy said it but it slipped
real fast it's kavakazi or some kind of
area in afghanistan so is it still
islamic state
iran
syria
and now
they're just adding letters they're not
making up new names
who knows this i would think starting to
become like the who i don't know i would
say that um
that's another variant
once once
and you know we haven't really said
anything about it but once we
get as many people as we can get out
then the shit's gonna hit the fan yeah
yeah i'm sorry i'm i'm sorry i said it
like that
that's true but
but that but but but but that's where i
am right now because
there's nobody gonna put there's nobody
over there that is gonna be able to put
the check on
the taliban
and isis
when we leave
and china's not going to do it china
china is a ally
of the taliban
so um expect
some things to happen and go god
god help him but expect some things to
happen
um in the area of israel
um
they are
right they are wild animals over there
yeah like they truly are 100 percent
pure emotions right to kill
to hunt to i mean it's like like a pack
of wild dogs would be more tame than
these guys that's how out of control
they and they hate america the most yeah
they i mean they've had 20 years to
build that up just recently oh yeah v
for vendetta a capital v for vendetta
because i'll tell you what they have
been simmering and they're very patient
people so i'm not giving joe a free pass
anymore if this is just dementia or
stupidity i'm not gonna do it anymore
because i really think that they're well
aware that in order to take down trump
and his followers because they're so
large you have to you have to take down
america boy when he said that they're
fighting for the soul of america i hope
you understand now what that meant yeah
oh yeah
yeah mary
mary mary says uh
biden has blood he he literally today
he literally today that's why i said if
there was an election
there's no way he can come back from
this
the next three years are lame duck
there are people that have
that have died today because of
decisions of the president of the united
states of leaving them over there the
result of the result the more the
results are
that people are going to be stuck
because of this president over there and
god help us if more people die that are
stuck over there because of joe biden
he's gonna have more blood but he
literally has blood on his hands today
right does it stick does it stick to
kamala too
no i don't think so
now look listen listen the only reason
why i say that is because the president
makes that choice now if she comes out
and she says he listened to me
and i'm the one that had the final you
know i i mean i i
that this was 50 50. if she comes out
and said it is 50 50 yes
but if she remains quiet
so do you think it was a mistake that
she said she was the last person in the
room when he made the decision to pull
out of afghanistan nobody really
listened to that
no
she said it really
an amazing immediately
she could be relevant
right and that's what i'm saying none of
the so is anybody held accountable
because the media is not going to show
it after this is done after after they
leave they are going to come back and
say that this was a win for the biden
administration because he got out any
american and then got out i don't you i
mean what i said they're already saying
it
i mean i've been seeing a whole lot of
people slam biting for it this time for
them so have i but cnn i just saw a
person on there today saying that they
think he did a great job with
afghanistan yeah i guess most of the
hosts have been slamming them though
well i hope they continue that after
these americans get out because not all
the americans got out and i'm afraid
they're gonna go with that speaking
talking point that we got all the
americans out that wanted to come out
i'm really afraid they're gonna say that
what
what i think might happen is even though
they've been hard on joe
cnn msnbc
abc
all of the alphabet networks have been
hard on joe for afghanistan
what i have noticed
until today
they were moving a little bit farther
away from afghanistan and starting to
talk about the covet thing again
to bring that up to push afghanistan off
but now this is happening so now this is
slapping them right back in the face
they got to say something
you know
but
i mean for me i've seen them be
consistent on slamming joe
for the last two weeks
on afghanistan
and and i mean slamming the people in
his administration too
um oh yeah
i'm like damn yeah y'all doing better
than fox
you know but
you know i i don't see them coming back
and defending him
because
americans
unless they stop
broadcasting that americans are left
over there let's just say august 31st
no more planes okay
we know americans are gonna be left over
the media has to report on americans
being left behind
especially when we start seeing social
media blow up and the people i'm here
i'm still there right now
they got to and then they got to blame
that
on joe so
for for a while
they're going to be blaming joe because
of people being left over there and
god help
the examples of torture or or or the
examples of
people that could die
beyond october i mean um beyond august
31st i pray that you're right but i pray
that you're right that they are going to
show it but look at the southern border
the suffrage that goes on down there and
the things that are going on down there
and people have cell phones and msnbc
cnn abc their sh their track record is
they play 30 seconds of it and then
that's all the coverage for the entire
news cycle
i don't know if they
i don't know if they will play i
understand that i'm just saying i hope
that you're right on this because if not
the great enabler
sack of potatoes is going to get up
there and tell you that again her little
comment that she makes her snarky
comment all americans that want it out
got out you know if you want if you're
an american and you want to get out you
can get out right right right she's a
great greatest enabler of this
administration and i'll tell you i don't
know how she can sleep at night because
the lies that she says is going to burn
her in hell
out of the whole entire administration
she's the one i dislike her more than i
do kamala
well
yes
yes i i mean i i i see i see i see where
you're going
with that we just
we just remember though
she has to
that's her job that's her job is i mean
and and all i mean to lie it's just
shame that that's what press secretary's
jobs are i i just want to press
secretary
i know and i don't i don't want this
anymore i this shouldn't be accepted in
america no it shouldn't it shouldn't we
should want account you know what and
and um before we go i said this i i said
this and i know the java break this
country was built on checks and balances
that's why you have three levels of
government
not two not four you have three it's
supposed to be a checks and balances
uh and and that's why he had majority
and in congress and stuff and i mean
the the forefathers
had to be geniuses
i mean if they were to come back and see
how dumb we have got then they would be
pissed off
but there are no more checks and
balances there's no more oversight
in congress today there's no more checks
and balances in the us government
because people have gone into their
corners about
i ha i have to be right
i have to be right
but when you get the but when you get
one side saying i have to be right when
you and you get the other side where's
it i i got to be right then the country
doesn't move anywhere because now you
got a tug of war
and the country's in the middle and the
country's going
but the country's not going anywhere
and then you get people coming on tv
defending
uh liars schemers right um uh uh you
know um bad bad presidents bad
legislators on both sides uh
yeah and and that's why we here on the
wayne and pre-show we slap them all down
i already don't care i don't i don't
care for anybody in washington dc i
think i think all of them should should
be removed i think that their pensions
should be cut i think that their
medicals
should be um taken away i think they
should be
i think they should go back um join the
salvation army and start planting our
trees for arbor day i don't i don't
think that they should be
in charge of anything because they
aren't helping the country they aren't
they're
or hurt i wouldn't even put him as a
walmart greeter at this point in time
you screw that up you screw the business
up oh they would they they'd find a way
to screw it up
right be like oh hell no oh i don't like
this career i'm out of here
i'm going to
xavier xavier right we need real
conservatives
on the left and right and you know what
i'm glad you said on the left and right
because there are some conservatives on
the left there are i don't care what
nobody says there are some
conservative-minded people
on the left
you need to trade parties they are more
they are more socially liberal
but they're fiscally conservative yes
the fiscal part of it has to come home
right the physical because
you're draining this thing right now and
we even have people on our side that are
uh
socially liberal
we have people on our side that will do
anything out there and i mean they'll go
out there
to to the parties and all their they are
socially liberal there i mean you know
they drink and
party and they go to the conferences and
put the put the um put the socks on the
doorknob and do whatever they had oh i
thought you just say put the dress on
that's elected officials that too i
think
yeah over time so um
it's bad okay so ladies and gentlemen we
gotta go uh
cbd cbd.com forward slash bring the pre
don't forget to go there i think i think
we're done with them this month too
um
but yeah cbd lion uh four slash wayne
the pre don't forget to check them out
uh twenty percent
of their products
and there you go um and also yeah so um
we are gonna
leave it like that keep your eyes
close and open to the
um the news
and um pray for what's going on over
there because we don't know what's going
to happen we don't know what's going to
happen but uh
we hope that y'all have a great weekend
all right
um
[Music]
let me put this up here too
never quit water.com never quit water um
we had this we had a guy
tim he came on yesterday
uh if you have any questions you can
watch it watch the video from yesterday
or yeah
uh you can go to never critwater.com
sign up and he will ask he will answer
your questions immediately
you can do that too all right with that
said it's time for us to go
uh
my people are tired i'm giving them the
weekend off
if it happens if it blows up
we'll be back stay here get the app
that's how you'll know get the way to
pre app on the android iphone if you got
the app you'll know whenever
it hits the fan
that's right
download the app
um
okay so
[Music]
okay